do it to infinity and your mom when's
the last time you were watching one of
your favorite Disney flicks and thought
to yourself I know that voice you're not
alone you'd be shocked to see which
stars are behind the mic of some of your
favorite animated characters like the
Harry Potter star who you had no idea
voice Disney royalty so how many of
these celebrity voice actors can you
guess let's find out billy goat and
gruff right right right sorry guys girls
girls of course the actors they chose to
voice moana was definitely a perfect fit
for the island princess first of all
she's from hawaii so she knows all about
life in the sand and second she looks
pretty much exactly like moana do you
know who she is it's Allie eek ravallo
don't be surprised if you couldn't place
her voice Moana was out Leah's very
first role since then she's gone on to
sing live at the Oscars plays Ariel in
the Little Mermaid live on ABC and voice
Moana again in Ralph breaks the internet
talk about living a fairy tale the star
who played Maui also looks a lot like
the character he voiced you know Maui is
a hero to all you doing great this
gentle giant loves fast cars skyscrapers
and Jumanji he's also a retired
professional wrestler think you know him
of course it's the rock Dwayne Johnson
really wanted to play Maui so he could
be a part of the Disney family and
represent his Samoan roots at the same
time he even played cheerleader behind
the scenes and made it his mission to
keep the cast encouraged and motivated
which sounds exactly like something the
rock would do the celebrity who gave her
voice to mallanna's mom Cena is more of
a singer than an actress she's been a
judge on the masked singer dated ed
Sheeran oh and she's also a Pussycat
Doll sometimes who we wish we were
what we wish we could do so who do you
think it is that's right it's singer
dancer and voice actress Nicole
Scherzinger like her Moana co-star alii
Nicole was also born in Hawaii and after
Moana she went on to voice another
Disney character Moe's mom in Ralph
breaks the Internet Ralph breaks the
Internet brought back all the major
Disney Princesses but what's even more
fun is who they got to voice them let's
start with Ariel's I have to assume you
me to deal with an underwater sea witch
the actress who brought her voice to the
role is no stranger to Disney she was
Barbie in Toy Story 3 and voiced Helen
of Troy in the hercules TV series do you
think you know who it is
it's Jodi Benson and if that name sounds
familiar it's probably because you know
her from her most famous role the
original voice of Ariel in the Little
Mermaid I don't see how a world that
makes such wonderful things could be bad
she's also the one who sings Oliverio
songs
so next time you're rockin out - part of
your world you have Jodi to think what
about Pocahontas Disney wanted to make
sure they got a Native American woman to
voice the original role so of course
they wanted to do the same in Ralph
breaks the Internet what kind of a
princess are you they decided to go with
someone who'd been Pocahontas before do
you know who they chose it's the
phenomenal Irene Bedard
the original Pocahontas the character
design for the princess was actually
modeled after Irene so she brings a lot
more than her voice to the role this is
how we say hello Wynn got Bo in 1995 she
made People magazine's 50 most beautiful
people list
so by now you've probably noticed that
Disney likes to bring back their
original princesses they did the same
thing with Belle in Ralph's breaks the
internet well there's a lot to unpack
here so this steering wheel you sing of
the actress who voiced her was the
original Belle back in 1991 and starred
as Fantine in lay miserab on Broadway do
you know her
it's Paige O'Hara who auditioned five
times for the role of Belle because she
wanted it so badly and good thing she
got it because she's been Belle in Ralph
breaks the internet both Beauty and the
Beast sequels and video games like
Kingdom Hearts peed really is Belle the
voice of Rapunzel entangled has a weird
talent for making us cry in a walk to
remember and this is us she's always
pulling on our heartstrings oh and she
was also a pop star as a teenager do you
know who she is it's Mandy Moore Mandy
says she takes being a Disney Princess
very seriously though she's also been
the villain a couple times she played
Mia's bully Atlanta in The Princess
Diaries but still she much prefers being
Rapunzel
she even voiced the character again in
Ralph breaks the internet do people
assume all your problems got solved
because a big strong man showed up the
voice actor they chose to play Flynn is
just as funny in real life can't you
picture me in a castle of my own because
I certainly can he recently made his
big-screen debut as a superhero and
Shazam he was also Fandral in Thor any
idea who he could be
it's Zachary Levi who described playing
a Disney Prince as a bucket-list dream
the only downside to being entangled
Mandy and Zach had to record all their
dialogue alone Zach hopes that the next
animated project he does will be a bit
more social and we can't help but agree
so you probably know the amazing
actresses who bring Elsa and Anna to
life in frozen but what about some of
the other major characters who appear in
the sequel let's start with clean I do
know herself when I was little my mother
would sing a song about a special river
called otter holla Elsa and Ana's mom is
an amazing singer the actress who gave
her her voice has starred in Westworld
and across the universe where she got to
show off her amazing voice do you know
who she is clean I Doudna is Evan Rachel
Wood she was born into a musical family
with parents who can both act and sing
but Evans admitted that her children
aren't so hyped about her technically
being a Disney princess now instead they
always ask her questions about Josh dad
who voices Olaf lightning-round boys
against girls Mandy Moore isn't the only
this is a star to voice a Disney
character one of her children from the
hit show took on the role of lieutenant
matias in frozen 2 any idea who he is
yep it's sterling K Brown while sterling
tends to go for live-action roles like
the one in black panther frozen 2
actually wasn't his first animated film
he also voiced scary in Angry Birds 2
where he actually got to work with Josh
GAD for the first time he voiced Chuck
okay so Kristoff and Anna are totally
meant to be but who is it that voice is
the iconic character alongside Kristen
Bell yes now back up I deal with this
crook here you know this performer from
Glee where he ended up with the one and
only Rachel Berry
after making us all fall in love with
his voice do you remember him it's
jonathan groff an actor and singer who
got his start on Broadway right
alongside Lea Michele he also played
King George in Hamilton but the best
news ever is that Groff would love the
chance to play Kristoff in frozen on
Broadway
we need tickets stat
brothers ian and barley from onward are
kind of like brothers in real life these
two actors are known for their roles as
comedic superheroes one of them's really
into spiders while the other is more of
a star-lord can you guess who they are
it's Tom Holland and Chris Pratt the duo
had so much fun behind the scenes they
literally lost their voices the actors
who both have brothers of their own made
time in their busy schedules to film
together as much as possible
don't these two make work look fun the
actors chosen to voice on words
Manticore is one of Hollywood's biggest
names she won both an Oscar and a Golden
Globe for her role in the help and she
was also recently the voice of a little
duck named dab dab in Dolittle so what's
your best guess of course it's Octavia
Spencer
Octavia used to be typecast in small
roles often as a nurse before she
skyrocketed to fame after the help since
then she's been in countless movies like
hidden figures and instant family and
now she's even played a Manticore the
comedian cast as officer gore is known
for being a baby Cobra and a hard-knock
wife she's also one of the stars of the
Netflix rom-com always be my maybe think
you know who she is it's Ali Wong she
was stoked to play officer Gore because
she's one of the first openly gay
characters in a Disney movie but this
isn't Ali's only Disney voiceover credit
she was also the voice of felony in
Ralph's breaks the internet and she says
she's always down for more animation you
know some kids play rougher than others
so before she was shepherding sheep the
actress who voices Bo Peep in Toy Story
4 was busy being a secretary in
ghostbusters now she plays Mima in young
Sheldon so who is she it's Annie Potts
and she's always been Bo Peep she even
voiced the character in the recent lamp
life short on Disney plus one of Annie's
biggest inspirations is Dolly Parton so
she loves any opportunity to play a bond
I
even an animated one like Bo this next
actress took on the role of bad dog
Gabby Gabby which is funny considering
she now stars in a show called good
girls and her hair in real life flips an
awful lot like Gabby Gabby's good choice
around here don't have kids are you too
lost think you know who she is it's
Christina Hendricks the fiery redhead
who starred in Mad Men Christina
loves playing a strong powerful female
character and you can actually catch her
in a new animated movie that just
released
she plays officer Jackie in Scoob duckie
and bunny are the perfect characters for
two best bud comedians to voice the BFFs
to voice these characters fell into a
deep bromance as soon as they met then
they started a hit sketch comedy series
before starring in some solo projects
think you know who they are that's right
it's keegan-michael key and Jordan Peele
better-known together as key and Peele
the duo had fun improvising a lot of
their lines for the film one of their
favorite habits as friends is randomly
singing to each other so they just had
to sneak that into the movie did you
know that three of Braves characters
were voiced by Harry Potter stars let's
start with Merida this princess needed a
truly unique voice to bring her to life
and this Scottish born actress was the
perfect choice she had roles in Lassie
and even played Helena ravenclaw in
Harry Potter any idea who she could be
it's Kelly Macdonald and she was so
proud to have starred in Pixar's very
first female lead movie she voiced
Merida again for a Ralph's fakes the
internet because could you even imagine
anyone else in the role
another Harry Potter start lent her
voice to Queen Eleanor she played Polly
the parrot in Doolittle can you guess
who it is
I asked you what do you expect it's Emma
Thompson she's a huge fan of voiceover
work and even voiced the elder in the
golden globe-winning film
missing link and of course she also
played divinations expert professor
Sybill Trelawney but we've saved the
most surprising Harry Potter star for
last this is the one you've all been
waiting for do you know which huge Harry
Potter star lent their voice to Lord
Dingwall here's your hint he is quite
literally huge think you know who it is
it's Robbie Coltrane better known as
Hagrid from the Harry Potter series
Robbie had so much fun working behind
the mic and bringing such a different
character to life and it was a lot less
work than his role as Hagrid
you don't always have to wear layers of
heavy robes when you're in a cozy
recording studio so how'd you do let us
know how many voices you got write in
the comment section down below hit that
like button if you had fun and don't
forget to subscribe to the themes for
more thanks for watching we'll see you
next time
[Music]
you